♪♪
ALL: Hi, we're the Try Guys.
Ahh!
♪♪
That's Zach over there.
Oh, he is falling off
of me.
Next to him sittin' pretty
is Eugene.
Do you wanna talk
about your package?
Our beautiful married one
is Ned.
We're about to blow
your mind.
Perfect one right here,
Keith.
Everybody gets lost
in this beauty.
We're so close
as friends.
You know each other
well enough to know
- where the line is.
- Yeah.
And how to just
tip-toe on it.
Like Ned does't like
being hit.
- He'll react real big.
- No, I don't like--
Guys, stop it!
♪♪
We have a new show
coming to YouTube Red
called "Squad Wars."
- Oooh!
- Oy-yoy-yoy.
We're bringing a bunch
of cool famous squads together
and putting them
to the challenge.
Each week, they're gonna
learn a new skill,
and at the end
of the day,
we get to judge them.
What's really fun
is that each episode,
two of us split off
and join a squad.
So, we're not just hosts,
we get to join in on the fun.
We're doing synchronized
swimming.
- What?
- We're doing bullfighting.
- [record scratch]
- No, we're not.
- No, we're not!
[laughter]
That would be great,
though.
- Bullfighting?
- I had you there.
I had ya.
We got pro wrestling,
we got NASCAR pit crews,
we got Bollywood dancing.
It's just like
reality television,
but nothing like it
at all.
Ca-caw! Ca-caw!
Find out who nails it.
[crowd cheering]
And who fails it.
[screaming]
- It's "Squad Wars."
- Only on YouTube Red.
Pow.
[explosion sound]
Can we add an explosion
in after?
- Can we put an explosion in?
- Yeah, okay, cool.
To make us look cool.
♪♪
That's a wrap.
[shattering]
Oh, my God,
I am so sorry.
I don't know why
I threw that.
That was--
Is it gonna--
is it still work?
♪♪